oh
[Musique]
françois
g j'ai une lettre pour toi une lettre
quoi montre ça monsieur françois l'île
aux enfants dit reid du maul qui me lira
ce qu'il ya dedans en body dont aussi
j'ai pas trop personnel
voyons
cher françois pourrais tu nous raconter
un jour pourquoi l'île d'er casimir est
devenue l'île aux enfants signé olivier
c'est une bonne idée ça didot résigné
j'ai compris j'ai accompli je vais vite
me préparer lors d'une dépêche ouais les
enfants les enfants venaient voir rené
année venez installez vous tient rythme
et la danse
allez voilà je vais vous raconter
comment l'île d'er casimir est devenue
l'île aux enfants
c'était au 16e siècle il ya 400 ans
c'est l'époque des grands explorateurs
des conquistadors souvenait de
christophe colomb de magellan de cortez
et puis bien d'autres ces explorateurs
cherchait des terres nouvelles et
c'était très cruel très féroce
un jour un navire jette l'ancré devant
l'île d'er casimir us et des chaloupes
sont mises à la mer et sa proche de la
plage manque de chance c'était les
soldats les plus féroces qui existait à
cette époque là les casimir us les
regards d'approché avec inquiétude il
n'avait encore jamais vu des hommes
alors bon c'est bien ils se méfient et
heureusement qui se méfie parce que les
soldats attrape les animaux qui se
trouve à portée de leurs mains et
commence par les tuer ils tirent des
coups de feu avec des espèces d'engins
qu'on appelle des arquebuses ça marchait
pas toujours très bien quelquefois ça
leur exploser la figure mantin les
casimir us n'avaient jamais entendu deux
coups de feu et ça leur a fait peur à
cette époque le règne des casimir us
n'avaient jamais cessé depuis des
milliers et des milliers d'années est-ce
que vous souvenez de casimir us premier
le roi qui avait chassé de lille les
féroces tyrannosaurus qui s'y trouvaient
je l'avais raconter une fois en souvenez
eh bien depuis des milliers d'années les
rois s'étaient succédé et un petit ennui
c'était que les quais 12h30 russe était
très très mauvais en calcul
il mélangeait tous les numéros des rois
ne savais pas si c'était le roi actuel
casimir us 931 casino ruhl
7849 ou casimir us 535 ennemis
535 ennemis anomalies qu'on n'a jamais
pu expliquer alors le roi de l'époque
qui connaissait pas son numéro était
très vexé et un jour idée puisque c'est
comme ça [ __ ] dick y a plus droit
et c'est à cette époque à peu près que
les soldats sont arrivés dans l'île donc
à cette époque les casimir russes vivent
sans roi est entré nous il s'en porte
pas plus mal pour ça alors les animaux
affolé vont voir les casimir us dans les
bois et leur disent écoutez les canines
russe vous êtes les plus grands vous
êtes les plus forts il faut nous aider
faut faire quelque chose
les kazimierz réfléchissent et ça y est
ils trouvent une idée qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va se déguiser en monstre pour
faire peur aux envahisseurs une bonne
idée nos et vous savez ce que ça donnait
à peu près je vous le montrez moi
casimir allait bien casimir voila voila
et me montrer ce à
[Musique]
quoi
non
alors évidemment quand les soldats ont
vu les casimir us déguisés comme ça ils
ont eu une panique terrible il fuyait
dans tous les sens à droite à gauche il
criait pousser des hurlements de frayeur
on les entendait dans toute l'île et à
toute vitesse il regagne la plage il
saute dans leur chaloupe il n'y a pas
assez de place pour tout le monde ils se
bagarrent il y en a qui rentra à la nage
tout le monde regagne le navire on lève
l'ancré hop le bateau s'éloigne à
l'horizon alors vous imaginez bien qu'en
rayon partir toute cette équipe et les
casimir us ont poussé un ouf de
soulagement ils étaient très contents
mais aussi c'était très étonné pourquoi
et bien sûr le rivage il restait deux
petits soldats en réalité c'est des deux
petits mousses qui étaient restées là on
les avait oubliés par les casimir us 10
mais il en reste deux il faut les
chasser allons-y ils arrivent ils font
les grands gestes pour leur faire peur
c'est très très très gros ges mais plus
gras comme casimir fait et plus les
casimir us faisait des grands gestes
pour faire toi optimus plus les petits
mousses rigoler ah ouais je me souviens
très bien mon grand père m'a raconté
alors où il faisait comme ça hu
et voilà et plus les casini russe
s'exciter en faisant de grands gestes
plus les petits mousses riet alors le
plus grand des casimir us
guy attendez je réglais ça il s'approche
tout seul vers les petits mousses en
faisant des grands gestes mais les
petits mousses s'approche de lui et
commence à le caresser il est car s ils
disent où tu es gentil toi t'es gentil
et très gentil cas si les risques très
très surpris il avait encore jamais
entendu parler le langage des hommes
cela répond gentil
gentil casimir us ce merci rires aussi
les petits mousses met à rire encore
plus fort elle casimir us rigole aussi à
son tour headline copains qui deviennent
amis alors en leur honneur les casimir
us organise un merveilleux festin on
apporte le plat national des casimir us
à table et qu'est ce que c'était c'était
le gloubi service que ça que le globish
10 c'est un mélange de confiture de
fraises de bananes écrasées et chocolat
en tout bien remuer et les casimir us on
était absolument fou n'est ce pas gami
ambitieux et ford inouïe les petits
mousses gutzeit tout ça très beau mais
pour remercier disent on va vous donner
quelque chose et casimir us il fouille
dans leur musette et le capitaine leur
avait donné pour l'an des jeunes et des
saucisses de toulouse et de la moutarde
il les offre aux casimir us les casinos
spread sacré qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc là qu'est ce que ça ça n'a pas
l'air très beau on va le mélange est
dans notre globi il le met dans le
groupe i à bien tous meilleurs mais le
tout y est sous sa traque ils appellent
ça le le gloubi boulga et ça devient
leur place ça va mais c'est d'ailleurs
toujours le mien 1 le gloubiboulga gens
mangent à radio bio bio bourgat adjoint
dans les amas souviens très bien mais
quelques jours plus tard les navires de
guerre reviennent en direction de l'île
d'er qassimi russe les barques sont
mises à l'eau et les soldats débarquent
sur la plage avec en tête le général le
général voit les deux petits mousses et
leur dit venez venez je viens vous
sauver je viens vous protéger et tous
les monstres là je vais les tuer et les
petits mousses qui 10 mai mais pourquoi
pas du tout ce sont nos amis ils sont
très très gentil puis d'ailleurs nous on
veut rester ici on veut rester avec
lesquels j'ai mis russe bondil général
mais est-ce que je peux quand même faire
quelque chose qu'on vous alors avec tim
moss kylie si vous avez à bord de la
saucisse de toulouse et de la moutarde
vous nous les apportez bienvenue le
général voilà et au moment de repartir
en notant une petite voix qui crient
parmi l'équipage et moi est-ce que je
peux rester aussi et les mots stylisme
évidemment que tu peux rester ici c'est
fait pour tous les enfants tous les
enfants sont les bienvenus lordon tous
les bateaux qui étaient là y avait pas
mal d'enfants de petits mousses sont
tous restés sur l'île avec les casimir
us les soldats regagner leur chaloupe et
le général au moment de partir surtout
on est dire mais dites moi dites moi
cette île là comment l'appeler vous
alors tous en choeur
de la plage les casimir us et les
enfants ils ont répondu c'est l'île aux
enfants les spas casinos voient là et
depuis ce jour là lille ça paie comment
l'île aux enfants voilà
enfin enfin je ne le comprends pas il
doit prendre le bateau qui part dans une
heure et il ne connaît rien des pays
qu'il va visiter
julie tu m'écoutes tu me parlais excuse
moi mais je suis très occupé il faut que
je termine le sandwich de casimir et je
n'aurais jamais fini il prend le bateau
dans une heure il ne faut quand même pas
une heure pour préparer un sandwich à
ben écoute ce qui m'a écrit tu
comprendras
hr julie je voudrais que tu me prépares
à sandwich pour mon voyage surtout ne
fait rien de compliqué et bien devoir il
ne te demande qu'un sandwich toussaint
pour me laisse moi continuer s'il te
plaît donc je sais plus aujourd'hui la
rto merci mais il seulement du jambon de
la moutarde du beurre des fraises une
tomate de la mayonnaise du solution de
la crème chantilly beaucoup dans soit
d'esprit des petits suisses à la
groseille du lard fumé des épinards de
la confiture d'ananas qui se fait mais
je ne fais que commence il regarde y en
a sur toute la longueur du rouleau c'est
incroyable julie julie casimir te voilà
en fait vient dit mon dieu oh mais ce
n'est pas à toi que je parle c'est à
julie de nommer mais julie est très
occupée par partons sandwich mais
justement julie j'espère que tu ne vas
pas terminée non j'en suis à peine à la
moitié à bon ça va parce qu il faudrait
rajouter des cadres mais il faut les
mettre juste avant la crème de marron
c'est tout enfin je crois oui je veux
quelque chose de très simple
casimir si tu ne veux pas te perdre en
route il faut que tu viennes étudier un
petit peu les pays que du va traverser
ce n'est pas la peine je connais tous
c'est très facile
oui bien à plombs quand même les enfants
ils vont nous aider route n'est vraiment
pas la peine je n'ai pas besoin de leur
aide
on verra bien on verra bien les enfants
venaient nous allons faire un jeu pour
absolument que nous étions casimir venez
vous voulez mais c'est inutile je
connais tous
casimir part en voyage il a décidé de
visiter tous les pays qui ont une
frontière commune avec la france et la
vertu tous les pays qui la touche vous
les connaissez oui et vos essais oui non
oui on va voir commençons par le nord
comment s'appelle
la belgique l'a très bien ah oui là quel
est le nom de la capitale de la belgique
très bien bruxelles capitale de la
belgique à la belgique oui ensuite ce
petit pays
le grand duché du luxembourg très bien
la
connaît le nom de la capitale grand
duché du luxembourg
laurent fignon c'est tout cela mais
c'est justement luxembourg ah bah oui
évidemment rouge le cache complètement
là tout petit pays qu'une grandes
étiquettes les 100 casinos répond
maintenant
casimir quel est le nom de ce pays celui
là c'est facile ça alors c'est là le le
6 et le mexique et
quel est le nom de sa capitale new york
c'est une bonne réponse alors qu'elle
aimait long de ce pays les enfants
ah non non c'est l'allemagne
jugé le nom de sa capitale
bonne
alors je vais bien bon assez bonne voilà
l'allemagne capitale de bonn à la d112
le nom de ce pays
très bonne réponse à 10 vous connaissez
le nom la capitale de la suisse non
à ben oui oui à l'irak vers les piquets
en suisse
à casimir maintenant casimir bref quel
est le nom de ce pays qui a une
frontière avec la force ça c'est une
sait quelque chose maintenant c'est une
chaussette annonce est un pays c'est ça
s'appelle un ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle chez toi ça souffle et lui
à l'italie oui c'est ça à licques alger
a pas trouvé seul nom et ce n'est pas la
fin d'une chaussette mais la forme d'une
botte torigni et du connaît le nom de la
capitale de l'italie et bien c'est c'est
ça c'est ça ce soir ils ont tous aimé y
alors l'italie et
ce pays
jeune j'allais dire et le nom la
capitale
la capitale
madrid
ah bah oui oui madrid oui images leader
en espagne catherine hugues tissandier
prêt et bien voilà casimir tu as appris
beaucoup de choses maintenant tu vas
partir à droite tu nous enverra des
cartes postales
projet
je crois que je vais être obligé de
retarder un peu mon départ
pourquoi casimir maintenant tu connais
tous les nous les pays que de la visiter
et tu as le sandwich que tu souhaitais
mais non justement ce n'est pas un
sandwich de voyage ça lorsque j'aurais
mangé ce sens drx là il me faudra au
moins une journée pour le digérer alors
hu
[Musique]